this video is sponsored by squarespace
stick around until the end of the video
to learn more about squarespace and to
get access to a special offer
time
most of us need more of it and it's lack
of time that prevents us from doing the
things we want to do
like working out
while it's easy to dismiss a lack of
time as an excuse the truth of the
matter is that some people really don't
have time
you never know what's going on in
someone else's life
but i would argue that most people can
find at least an hour a week or maybe 10
minutes a day to do something
the problem here though is that it
doesn't seem like enough so why waste
time on training that won't be enough of
a stimulus to affect any real change
when you could just sit down for 10
minutes instead
well here's the thing every hour counts
and if you can only manage an hour a
week that's still far better than
nothing and you can still make gains you
just need to moderate your expectations
prioritize and train smart
[Music]
in a recent video i explained how
training every single day if possible
could be really good for you however now
i'm going to discuss the opposite end of
the spectrum how training just once a
week for one hour can still be enough to
get some amazing results so obviously
you're not gonna get as good results
training just one hour a week as you
would do training you know for five six
seven eight i'm not suggesting that you
got your way to do this however if
you're not training because you think
there's no point cause you've got so
little time then i'd ask you to
reconsider so what i'd personally do if
i only had an hour to train per week is
to split my training into six 10 minute
mobility sessions because i think for
most people mobility is the most
important thing that's missing if you
only do mobility training for 10 minutes
you could do five different stretches
for two minutes each and that would be
enough to make a significant difference
if you did it almost daily to the way
you move the way you feel your energy
levels it could help to reduce injuries
and aches and pains
so specifically the five stretches i
would do is probably a deep squat i do
some kind of deep forwards lunge to
stretch the hip flexors i do something
overhead perhaps a hang i do a bridge
for my back perhaps and a pancake
stretch
if it's burning calories and losing
weight that you're interested in then
there's even more good reason to train
even if you only have an hour a day
i explained in a previous video that
skipping for just 10 minutes a day could
burn anywhere between 100 and 300
calories depending of course on your
weight and your intensity use a weighted
rate for added credit
of course you need to take this with a
pinch of salt consider things like our
bmr but worst case scenario that's going
to add up to about 600 calories a week
best case scenario maybe 1 800 and
that'll make a huge difference to your
overall energy balance
you can make a similar dent with two
half-hour metcon workouts or a run
maybe this would even be more effective
find this boring then how about meeting
up with friends for an hour of football
or something similar a gentle walk can
do a world of good too
as for building muscle and strength well
that's a little bit more difficult but
it's certainly still not impossible and
definitely not a waste of time
so a half hour workout is probably long
enough to get a warm up in and to
perform some near max lifts on two
exercises so if you take 10 minutes to
warm up and you do four sets in total
you're gonna need about 12 minutes of
rest between sets that's three minutes
each but that still leaves a good eight
minutes for the actual lifts which is
plenty you don't actually spend that
long lifting a weight especially if
you're only doing like four reps
warm up with working sets and you could
then do two sets of the deadlift the
bench press the squat or the military
press and as you can fit in two sessions
you can do all four of those things
you'll need to be very efficient and
you'll need to go easy so as not to rush
your work out and hurt yourself i'm not
exactly recommending this i'm just
making the point that it's certainly
doable and you'd likely make some
strength gains especially as a newbie
for building size of aesthetics is your
priority i'd recommend doing some
massive drop sets targeting a push
movement a pull movement your legs your
traps and some curls a drop set could
mean performing a heavy bench press to
technical failure then immediately
lowering the weight and then switching
to push-ups
if you take relatively short rest times
and pump out three sets you're gonna
feel the burn and the doms the next day
trust me and you can do that in 10
minutes again i'm not saying this is
optimal or desirable i'm just saying you
can certainly get some benefits from it
what's more to the point though is that
you actually only need minimal stimuli
in order to maintain muscle
jeff nippard made a great video on this
he found one study that showed that
simply walking could significantly slow
muscle loss during time off the gym
maintaining regular activities can do
even more and better yet according to
one study reducing training volume to
just one-ninth of your usual could be
enough to maintain muscle mass entirely
for up to 32 weeks there's an argument
to be made that for a lot of people just
maintaining actually makes a lot of
sense once you're at the point you want
to be at
and if nothing else this will prevent
the worst atrophy and deterioration the
body is dynamic always moving and if you
aren't getting better you're getting
worse
there's a fact that you can easily train
to learn skills in an hour that might
mean learning martial arts getting
better at skipping learning to juggle
learning to handstand or even improving
your technique on specific lifts or
calisthenics moves remember strength is
a skill well remember when used to go to
martial arts lessons for one hour a week
as a kid you still learned martial arts
right maybe you weren't bruce lee and
you would have been more formidable had
you trained more frequently but the
point is you can definitely learn in
that short time you probably did the
same with piano or violin or something
spreading it out is better as it greases
the groove and takes advantage of the
spaced learning effect but either way
you can get some benefits and learning
after all is one of the most important
aspects of fitness and performance but
then there are all the other less
obvious benefits of even just doing an
hour of exercise per week it gets you
outside often it's social and it's
amazing for your mental health
boosting your mood aiding with your
sleep and stimulating neuroplasticity
this is a topic that's actually near and
dear to my heart as i noticed that as a
parent a lot of youtube content is
simply not aimed at me anymore sure
those perfect morning routine videos
sound great but there's zero chance of
me doing a single one of those things
when i'm feeding my daughter and
changing my son's nappy
again i'm not recommending that you only
train for an hour a week that certainly
is not the aim of this video but rather
i'm saying that if you only have one
hour and a lot of people genuinely do
you should still train in that hour
because that's better than nothing and
in fact it can do a huge amount of good
a huge thank you to grant for filming
this one he shot 90 of the dynamic shots
here and they came out amazing i
literally just threw a gimbal at him and
a new anamorphic lens and i said we've
got three hours as always they did an
incredible job and thank you to the fat
zebra cafe in vista and anytime fitness
bista both for letting me film on their
sites you guys probably know anytime
they're a great brand of gym and my
personal choice and the fat zebra cafe
is an amazing cafe if ever you're in
bista that makes fantastic coffee and
has a really great vibe
and if you like this training you can
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 which now
also comes with over two hours of
training videos
that will demonstrate and explain all of
the moves involved plus an 80 page ebook
and tons of extras i'll put a link to
that in description down below if you
want to check out my previous video on
why you can and should train every
single day then that should be popping
up right about now and as always thank
you so much for watching this one guys i
really appreciate it and bye for now
you know what else you can do quicker
than you think set up a website
especially if you use today's sponsor
squarespace so squarespace is a powerful
online platform that lets you develop
modern attractive and professional
websites really easily and with zero
coding so this way you can turn your
passion into a business in no time at
all squarespace makes this easy thanks
to a number of features
those include gated members only content
for easy revenue generation member
management inbuilt email communications
audience insights then you get fully
integrated commenting with threaded
comments replies and likes powerful
blogging tools for sharing content
categorizing posts scheduling publishing
and more and social media integration to
display posts from your social profiles
directly on your website or push social
media content automatically and if you
want to set up your own shop then you
can take advantage of the powerful
ecommerce capabilities with additional
third-party extensions providing
inventory management marketing
streamlined bookkeeping sales tax
reconciliation and filing and logistics
for shipping internationally so if you
want to start your own online business
but think it's going to be too
complicated then this might be a great
place to start as i said before the
bioneers started as a website first and
setting that up was honestly one of the
very best decisions i ever made
so go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
bioneer viewers can get 10 off the
purchase of their first site or domain
by going to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer today
thanks again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video and thanks so much
to you guys for sticking around
bye for now